hello rejects Greg here John here so
we're gonna check out the trailer just
drop for Kong Skull Island before we do
that though I got a gift
the this lovely husband and wife Oh
Mandy Jean Vasquez's her name has a
company called Firefly wood-burning
Firefly wood burning on Facebook I'll
put a link in the description box to do
a lot of cool stuff they sent me this
box I just opened it like this I haven't
seen what the gift looks like yet oh
that is awesome doom and ii-era husband
contacted me on Instagram so they were
fans of the channel gotta go check out
there this is seriously the first time
we're going to give you this this is oh
my lord this is amazing holy [ __ ] what
did you make all the zetas oh my gosh I
mean it touched the art go to go check
it out
holy crap this is really cool that's
awesome
oh this is something I gotta put this in
the background somewhere when we
actually like we film dude I love hope
okay now we have to live together that
is one of the coolest that's the coolest
thing anyone's ever sent us this is one
of my favorite renditions of me and you
yeah we just look so happy we're in
flames yeah oh this is the coolest part
of 20 so let me make sure okay yeah
facebook.com slash Mandy Jean Vasquez
with zis no s isn't her last name as
again they do anything custom sports
teams cartoon characters designs animal
stuff wow I had no clues gonna come out
that cool thank you guys thank you so
much you know this makes me really happy
that we have this channel oh yeah
anyway let's watch this trailer now just
premiere on Jimmy Kimmel I believe
these are photos of an island in the
South Pacific the place where myth of
science means takes place in the seven
can use explosives to take the earth
helping us to map the surface of the
island they're dropping bombs scientific
instruments interesting town no letter
monkey
magnificent
you knew that thing without here I'm
sorry for your manager if you want to
make their sacrifice worthwhile get us
home with proof monsters exist
your friend there can put that down what
the hell is this place that's cause he's
King around here comes pretty good team
he's so selflessly well you don't go
over to someone's house and start
dropping bombs unless you're picking a
fight
Kohn's gone beater dialing rich for The
Devil's live below us and with a cold I
call scope cars why you ever said that
name out loud before it sounds stupid
now that I say just you call them
whatever you want
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here a weird
trailer weird trailer this looks totally
weird yeah way prefered the first
trailer the relational comic-con this is
uh right here as a trailer is it's
everywhere for me it's all over like I
didn't know the whole first part with
the classic rock and all that like whoa
weird
I like that at first I'm like okay
they're putting us into vibe in the
world of the 70s you know like the
Vietnam War time and so they're
providing that kind of tone but then it
just started shifting and give this
weird but even the song they chose is
like upbeat and fun like and then I
thought like okay here comes the
contrast when you start smashing the
helicopters against really intense and
then it looks intense for a second and
then it becomes like a quirky adventure
coming yeah it has this mixture of like
oh this looks dark and heavy then it has
comedy in there and I don't really like
the look of Kong as much as I thought I
did at first everything in this trailer
for me is back and forth it's like
they're shots where I think Kong looks
really cool there's shots from Lang
there's I'm sur love really off though
yeah he's walking through the water in
[ __ ] best-case scenario I feel like part
of this trailer like parts of this
experience made me think it could be
awesome
when the trailer actually does at times
manage to come together it almost seems
like this might be just like embracing
itself is it kind of a big over-the-top
you know adventure movie clearly some
dark you know streaks and it's a really
like gritty helicopter crashing and like
gritty violence I guess like it just
seems totally weird
it totally does though it seems very
tonally strange it feels like a b-movie
like a b-movie of the King Kong story
see yeah this trailer to me is kind of a
mess and I don't know how to feel
because my hope may be at least based on
the trailers that maybe they just
embraced the kind of b-movie concept
this is it's a giant monkey that's gonna
destroy you know a city by the end of
the thing and then he's gonna go fight
Godzilla it is kind of b-movie and if
they really embrace that then like that
could be cool but this sort of looks
like especially judging by the first
trailer because the first trailer was
more like heavy head or Daria and now I
can't tell and because of all the [ __ ]
that's happening would be really trying
to make it more fun like yeah it feels
kind of forced but then I'm looking at
scenes like john c reilly is character
I'm like it's clearly out of a comedy
yeah was he even in the first trailer I
feel like they went back and reshot that
and like added it yeah if she seems he's
you know he was cast to be and now he's
cast in it already just a lot of the
humor just seemed very off right now
this trailer to me because I know that
they want to make the Godzilla vs King
Kong movie they're talking about that
movie they want to introduce like some
familiar monsters and then some new
monsters and I feel like they're really
trying to capitalize on this monster
universe they're trying to create
because I was like okay they're they
kind of just showed us Kong really early
in the trailer that's cool and then it's
like wait we got all these other
monsters though that we want to really
emphasize a lot on to sure to know what
direction it was taking who it is you
and I kind of worried the movie itself
might be a little all over the place
because I felt like Peter Jackson's King
Kong bouncing pretty well with like
there's King Kong hang out as a bunch of
other monsters to hear it's like they're
they're saying like Kong is God and then
every one of the monsters are you know
they're the devil so it's like okay Kong
is perceived as good then then there's
these monsters here but then I don't
kind of give a [ __ ] about the humans all
the sudden okay this is a really weird
messy trailer that just feels like a
bunch of mismatched parts put together
to me this is like if you just showed me
that we don't belong here chunk yeah I'd
be super psyched
the right balance of like oh my god this
kind of looks realistic but it's also
crazy you know it's also action not that
this trailer gave a lot of weight but I
now feel that there's a lack of miss
mystery and intrigue for is that yeah
that's weird
it kind of feels like it's all in your
face at the same time it's like I don't
really feel like I learn anything you
really don't feel like they gave
anything away
I just got it I just got really
concerned as all
yeah like I have a bunch of new concerns
I didn't have before it's the first she
was cool because it was just like it was
all about the go to the island they're
making Kong this mysterious figure and
then we're kind of wondering is it gonna
be like Godzilla and I feel like some
people complained about that like oh
it's gonna be one where we don't see
King Kong that much so we're gonna put
King Kong a lot in this trailer now I
don't know this it advertised your movie
yeah I just felt a little like unfocused
and it's really hard to tell what this
movies gonna be like as trailers these
days especially Warner Brothers films
are kinda confusing with their trailers
well this trailer almost feels pandari
to me I don't feel like this trailers
pitched me a complete movie so much as
its told me it's got this and also
there's comedy but also there's monster
and also it's serious but then like
Howie just seems so out of place here
yeah when john c reilly was like that's
the first time i said that out loud and
it sounds weird when i say it just
didn't seem like it was all really
meshing well together it seemed like
this visually looks cool like the
cinematography looks cool the designs
look really cool even though some of the
cgi looks a little off at times and
there's some some great images though i
mean yeah but it's like this show do you
know what to promote yeah exactly there
were moments during this where i was
like okay yeah like this does look good
awesome famous actors they calm then
monsters yeah aren't Tom Hiddleston's
here cool yeah like every major actor is
just gonna have their own storyline it's
gonna be like five different yeah here's
the John Goodman movie and then here's
the Tom Hiddleston movie here's the
Samuel Jackson movie I just really hope
it doesn't turn to one of those movies
where it's like it's only entertaining
when there's like monsters battling it
out yeah like you got a bunch of great
actors in here you got Tom Hiddleston
brie Larson John Goodman Samuel Jackson
when he cares you got all these like
different actors in here john c reilly
dude I get sort of a classic vibe in
that sort of just punched up to 11 the
way we like it now away from some of
these characters anyway John Goodman
being on all of everything you know who
sort of seems like an intellectual
spearhead of this then you got Tom
Hiddleston looks like the you know
strong dashing the thing is like these
are all action like they're all creature
features are all kind of action II but
I'll but not what looks like what it's
about you know a kink but it's about the
intervener if you look at King Kong you
spend a lot of time getting
Aaron and unfolding the mystery and the
thing is it's not boring because it's
sinister and so it's intriguing that way
or yes you know like that's what worked
when they redid King Kong appear Jackson
- and I'm saying that this doesn't feel
that yeah it doesn't this feels like
they're gonna get to the island in like
20 minutes in the movie and then a bunch
of fun shits gonna go down I don't know
no cuz they showed us that virtue is so
cool they showed us at least a couple
scenes that seemed like it took place
before they headed out but I hope that
maybe you know like with each each
character I get an intro like I feel
like this could easily because this
trailer so messy I feel like this could
easily have you know a random yeah more
first act than you were expecting I will
say I don't like this trailer but I'm
not determining that I'm not gonna like
the movie as I have a strong feeling
this trailer is just really off compared
to the final cut of this film that's the
thing about movie news being so public
now is like you get to sweat out in real
time those things where you're you know
looking around for humor and going they
probably shoehorn that in there cuz they
didn't wanted to track to series yeah
now it's super badass and awesome
because you know that's what's tracking
what I feel like this could easily be up
just a Frankenstein ii trailer from from
a studio that you know their marketing
team had a lot of notes because this is
what the kids want you know yeah exactly
alright guys make sure check out
maryjean Vasquez's site facebook go
check out her work they do custom stuff
so you'll contact her there'll be a link
in the description box for sure and if
you're new the channel you can subscribe
today rejects and get accepted John as
reasons to Jerry on Instagram in Twitter
he is the social media manager of
facebook.com slash blue house in
facebook.com slash liberal rejects all
right and listen and you could also
catch us on the movie trivia Schmo down
move March episode was just uploaded on
the Collider videos just when I PSA we
went against Clark wolf and Mark Riley
the Wolves of Steel so go check that out
and we'll end on a funny one today what
gas station does the turtle go to shells
yeah
take care of kids